we always enjoy honoring our community
heroes southwest medical hospice the
sponsors of this next segment introduced
us to carol johnson and her pet therapy
cat spencer
hello carolyn spencer welcome to las
vegas now
oh thank you very much we're honored to
be featured as um
southwest medical hospice
heroes of the month oh well we are
honored to shine some light on you and
what you do for our community so let's
talk about it what what drew you
to becoming a hospice care volunteer and
and what do you how do you make it
special
well it first started out with becoming
getting involved with pet partners of
las vegas
spencer is a very
outgoing cat he's
inquisitive
calm
and loves to be petted
so
when i noticed those traits i got them
involved with pet partners in las vegas
and then when pet partners of las vegas
partnered with southwest medical hospice
i was
drawn to becoming a hospice volunteer
from my
personal experience with our family
having my father in hospice for a time
and he received such loving care and i
would say that
spencer's visits with my father were her
his first hospice experiences what has
been the experience for you as a hospice
care volunteer for you and spencer as a
team i should say
southwest medical hospice has connected
us with
a self-professed
um loving cat mama
[Music]
spencer visits her
and
she just gets so much sensory comfort
just from petting him and he he lays
down on the bed next to her and
we just watched him just snuggle in next
to her and he probably laid there 40
minutes and she wanted him to be there
all day because
it was just so comforting to have that
animal contact she
lost her own beloved cat felix and she's
no longer able to take care of a cat of
her own so it's just
a small kindness to take time out of our
day my husband always goes with me thank
you
and um
just to
uplift someone's else's day
when they're going through a rough time
and
to just go in with a positive spirit and
uplift their day so let's talk about
how you would encourage other people to
get involved with hospice care and
giving back to the community in this way
i volunteer with my cat but
whatever your
interests are there's a role for you in
hospice to volunteer if you don't don't
wish to
connect one-on-one with the
patients there's a lot of behind the
scenes work there's a role for everyone
in hospice
southwest medical hospice and
we can all make a difference
my cat does his best he's the real hero
looks like a sweet cat there thank you
to southwest medical hospice for
sponsoring this segment if you want more
information you can call that number
702-671-1111 smalv.com